hey everybody and welcome to a ball
busting wild ride with stevo this week
we've got donnell rawlings and man he's
breaking my balls over here but boy is
he hilarious
and you know what i'm really excited to
tell you
that this is my new tour bus man
and i literally just woke up and i'm
going to show you how i do it man i
meditated i snuggled with wendy and now
i'm having my athletic greens because i
just woke up man
i have an empty stomach but that's no
problem with this kind of a supplement
man you can have an empty greens on a
totally empty stomach
and
it's delicious man
plus
a very healthy person told me not to
start drinking coffee until i've
hydrated myself
so dude
i'm hydrating man
drinking water with athletic grains
mixed into it and this athletic greens
dude it's like real food man and i don't
really eat that healthy these days so
makes me feel a lot better this is how i
start my day dude
it's just super quality bioavailable
ingredients that fill in my nutrition
gaps and it's delicious and a great way
to start my day and i want you to try it
go to athleticgreens.com
stevo and with your first purchase
they'll give you an entire year's supply
of immune boosting vitamin d for free
plus
five of these packets that i'm pounding
down right now
one more time
athletic athleticgreens.com
stevo
for
five free packs and a year supply
vitamin d
it's a dope deal man and i do it every
morning
like now i'm gonna start waking up let's
get into it
ladies and gentlemen donnell rawlings
yeah dude me being an actor that i am i
just want to take this opportunity to
say that that was the shittiest intro
that i've had in my 27 years of being
nobody or some people's ask somebody but
that interview i mean that intro sucked
yeah everybody gets the same [ __ ]
intro really yeah i wanted to feel
special man yeah okay
well there's always
a pie i do
when i record this episode is your dog
falling asleep right now she's not but
she's a mix of uh belgian malinois and
xanax
xanax yeah
no she i don't know if it was me because
i started talking or i was being
insulting to
her dad but she was excited outside on
the sidewalk yeah and the minute i made
this joke about you give me the shitty
uh intro she pretty much had the same
facial expressions as my baby mother
does when i talk
it's just like just disconcerned like
okay just keep talking keep talking it's
all it's all good you know every episode
of this podcast i give uh a different
adjective okay you know i i don't know
what what adjective i'll attribute to
this one we'll have to figure that out
as we go but how the hell are you i'm
doing good but i'm glad that you
explained adjectives and not pronouns
because that's a big thing in the street
now getting your pronouns right yeah
which i always get wrong and the only
pronoun and people know from my
experiences on chappelle's show my
experience is doing stand-up that the
only pronoun i use is sun
i call everybody's son get out on one i
don't have to worry about anybody and
whenever i say son nobody's ever said
but i identify as a daughter right right
i identify as a stepsister sure they
just answer son so i think that that's
the new thing we should do bro
everybody's son sounded all encompassing
yes sir yeah but when i'm performing my
art i find myself being careful why'd
you pause when you said that
wow you said it like some people might
have a different definition of it
you call it art i call it jack jurgen
off out of
helicopters basically
yeah but i'm mindful not to repeat the
same things too many times like like oh
have i said ladies and gentlemen you
know
like multiple times and i'll be thinking
that in my head but then all of a sudden
i start thinking is it
like is it okay to say ladies and
gentlemen is that like politically
correct now i think ladies and gentlemen
is a nice way of saying [ __ ] and
assets
sure
you know because
okay good i have a i've been known to
interrupt people now i'm apologizing man
so does he oh yeah
yeah and her voices are the same now too
yeah yeah my [ __ ] is so strained now and
i know not me i know people have made
fun of whatever right and i might have
been in a subtle way in the past made
funny fun of your voice sometimes sure
i'm paying the price right now yeah i
would talk about that no i'm paying the
price though cause i come up here and i
was like this [ __ ] your [ __ ]
sounds just like your [ __ ] so now you
got it you got to pay for it oh it's all
good man you know they
used to play this game my jackass plays
they they'd take my phone
before phones locked and [ __ ] you know
and then go through and they'd just call
random girls and pass around and they'd
be pretending to be me oh yeah and
nobody ever was the wiser they'd be to
get girls on the phone oh hey hey baby
you miss my wiener
i cannot get over the disinterest that
your [ __ ] dog had i want to look at
some old shows and see
should i pull a race car right now
no no she's she is mellow jello every
time sometimes she falls asleep really
it looks like she's falling asleep right
now well she probably will be where'd
you get that dog
i found her on the streets of peru so
that's actually a rescue dog
um yeah i um yeah that qualifies as a
rescue dog for sure yeah even though she
was doing pretty well for herself on the
street to prove evidently she was
overweight she was just chilling she was
in good health
um but yeah but we uh met in a foreign
country
yeah had we met before we met before but
we're just in passing probably like you
leaving i'm pretty we've shared the
stages together at the lab factory right
right but um yeah that was
the last time
i can remember us being somewhere that
close and like me and the conversation
which and everything it was in a cancun
for the um yeah just for laughs uh
cancun um
uh what is it festival yeah just for
last guys yeah yeah it was it was a
festival uh
like a vacation package kind of a thing
and they had me and you and and jim
jefferies and uh tom segura yep and who
else was your own uh bobby lee
we had everybody i remember the last
show we did
everybody had uh 10 minute sets
and you did 45.
[Laughter]
they tried to give you a 10 minute set i
mean no no i've been go ahead good good
well what it was it was uh
it was a [ __ ]
like a karaoke thing right the comedy
jam and you're supposed to tell a story
and then sing a song
and like
your story is supposed to be five
minutes
uh-huh so i just wanna know where the
[ __ ] the 45 minutes come from yeah what
story did you tell your life story what
no i mean i i told the story about how i
met motley crue when i was a little kid
i i'd have trouble believing that uh
that it took 45 minutes
but uh from from according to sources
sources would be made it felt like for
you sources would be me
and the reason why the sources would be
me because i go behind this [ __ ]
right and you just you told me what
happened you didn't give a [ __ ] about
the black man on deck you could care
less about that [ __ ]
you knew you had ufc to go to you know
you had to try to everything you could
do to ruin my set
and give me two minutes and this is
where they came and this
here's the real story
so we doing it and i was excited to see
you always like to see you perform
because you never know what the [ __ ] is
going to happen
also i knew that i wanted to perform
right and i think we had a heart out at
12 midnight yeah um i think you got the
mic at 12
25 i'm not big on numbers 25 26 27 20 29
somewhere around that right
and then you was doing your thing
and
they gave you the light
i didn't know that there wasn't light i
never okay those are like all these
lights everywhere that's that's your
truth steve it's not mine
and i know you're as new to light
because every time we hit your eyes you
would turn the other way
not to
engage the light right
and you know comedians are [ __ ]
comedians are assets because you running
the light you run it like you're doing a
marathon you did a sprint at a marathon
through the light like you ran it slow
did you ran it fast
right and then everybody's like and then
one of the producers like well danielle
um
you might not be able to go up that's
when i became racist and said why the
[ __ ] did y'all let this white boy go on
so long right
but it was like uh you might be to go up
you got to cut your time i was like why
it was like stevo's going along i'm like
so what's the worst that could happen
they [ __ ] pull the power
right when i'm on stage because like you
say you have to do stand-up and then you
do a song right and i chose to sing um
uh born in the usa okay because i did a
gauge of the audience and 99 of the
audience was white and there's no way
you can lose with white people
born in the usa for sure sounds like
it's gonna be a crowd favorite whatever
so i do my jokes i'm getting ready to do
it just the lights go off
he's nowhere around
he's fast asleep he fast asleep he fast
doing whatever the [ __ ] you're doing
rescuing dogs in mexico or whatever it
is right
and i'm singing born in usa this is the
lights on everybody's like [ __ ]
and i said okay listen everybody i said
this is gonna be a tough situation
but if everybody is quiet enough to
listen to because we're gonna have to
project if everybody's quiet enough we
could get it off if everybody pay
attention we could get it off and we
didn't have any light so i told
everybody to turn on their um self one
of the best moments i've had in comedy
told everybody turning cell phone lights
on
and then josh signals the band to play
no all we had was no um the drums
weren't being amplified the guitars
weren't it was just you could imagine
listening to music in a guitar just like
coming off the strings right but people
focused enough when they listened and we
did it and like though they the whole
damn resort area was it was lit up and
then you get everybody born and you i
don't know now that i'm thinking about
it might not have been a good idea to do
that in mexico
i might have been a reason we weren't
working there's like the [ __ ] is that
that might have been the reason why they
turned it off but it was one of those
night and you've been there where
you um
you've thrown a situation it's something
to probably never have you made an
adjustment to it and we adapted and i
could not wait
to see you
so i could curse you out about running
the light okay and you're such a
gentleman about you're not even upset
about it
well i mean like i'm mortified that uh
that you're that you are upset with me
um i i
no
i wasn't upset
okay a lot of i'm this is my honest
truth i wasn't upset and there's a lot
of comics was talking [ __ ]
right committees always talk [ __ ] sure
and they was like goddamn what the [ __ ]
is he doing this isn't jackets cause you
know they always go back to your past
and some people were saying some
some disrespectful [ __ ] right yeah and i
said let me explain something
we're lucky enough as comics
if we can get to the point where there
was a uh
a time period where we ruled everywhere
or we ruled on tv we ruled on film and
sometimes careers not to say your career
has fault or anything but it's hard to
be super hot for a very long time right
and i'm i made a point to let everybody
know this [ __ ] has done [ __ ]
that you dream you would do and still
has the pa um the passion
to still
want to go out and still do this [ __ ] so
yeah when they was talking [ __ ] i
[ __ ] was talking [ __ ] back well good
man i i appreciate that i thought it was
shed a tear but i guess
didn't get there you know what i'm dying
to know how long i've really my story
really was you know it was 35 minutes
wait a minute
it was wait a minute that was 35 minutes
it was 35 minutes on stage but then you
had told me a 10 minute story before you
did your 35 minutes
and the story you told me was the
craziest story
i've ever and i even made a joke about
it
you was talking about
it's you got so many stories jumping off
a plane out of a plane naked yeah
jerking off yeah that part to me was
some normal steve [ __ ] right but this is
when i realized the focus
and the dedication you have as an artist
yeah
not just jump out of playing that kid
not to jerk off but this is the part you
came yeah i blew alone
simultaneously as i fell out of the
plane i i i for me
i i try to put myself in people's
shoes or
their experiences right and even when i
close my eyes thinking about jumping off
a plane
which would probably be enough for me i
cannot imagine
blowing a load
out of the plane with the guys strapped
here i was getting say tandem too so
this guy of course isn't a friend of
yours well i mean he was uh they got
close really quickly yeah
we became close well hey man it sounds
like that sounds like pay-per-view
that's more than just film yeah well
that that's my uh my art that's my show
that's sure everybody
show you the footage i respect that yeah
he couldn't wait to show i knew he was
excited about showing the footage yeah
it sounds like i owe you an apology man
and and uh you know i don't think you
owe me apology i think you hold a guy
that
was behind you
he loved that no i'm not talking about
the skydiving oh i'd say like i'm
talking about the running the light
business that's no no i'm looking for it
what i'm doing now is i'm stalking your
calendar okay and i know that you uh
pull up on the laugh factory
at times i just can't wait to be there
and then like you're going after steve i
was like no no i'm going on next and i'm
gonna do that if i'm gonna do it so bad
i'm gonna lie and say i jumped out of
plane naked and jerked off
until i came on somebody so you can't do
it yeah i'm i'm evil bro all right he'll
get you back he's gonna have to yell at
you he'll get his revenge yeah i'll get
it well i dig that and uh you you were
did you do uh like a a full stand-up set
like in their little arena there yeah
yeah did you just disrespect me
you said little arena it was a big arena
ah it was a weird setup for an arena i
don't know it was but you're right it
didn't it was tall ceilings yeah it was
distance this stage was way too [ __ ]
big
you had to damn to catch an uber from
backstage
to the microphone i wasn't going for
that because i didn't want to be the guy
that walks and i got to keep waving so i
told him take the mic off the mic stand
i want it from backstage
that way i can uh connect with the
audience i don't have to do that that
that awkward walk like
waving and [ __ ] but you're right it was
um but it looked good for you because
when i first walked in here i just saw
your picture blessed i don't know how
how to set one for you but it was very
interesting setup it was it was an
awkward
show for me
and and i kind of attributed that to the
fact that that the audience was
comprised of people who were just there
for the festival it wasn't like my
people
so now i'm showing them videos of me
blowing a load i'm falling out of the
airplane and it's not necessarily like
my core target audience watching it not
the [ __ ] catchers it's not the cup
catchers
wait a minute so wait a minute you
actually showed the video yeah and you
told me the story the next day like the
video wasn't enough
you're like no donna i'm telling you
guys but you did i i heard people just
been saying good things about it oh well
thanks man it's uh yeah i mean i love it
dude i've been doing this this stand up
and the comedy club circuit for like 11
years kind of developed that craft and
then brought all my worlds together i
wanted to answer this question
because i know how it is um
in the world of comedy where
we get noticed by a certain genre or
certain thing that we do
right and then all of a sudden we flip
and want to do something else so for you
was it when for you to go from your
world to now i want to do stand-up how
did other comics take that or they
[ __ ] hated you told you
yeah there were some comics that were
totally not down with me
um
and that bothered me like a lot of
things bothered me but
you know when things bother you the best
thing to do is talk about it and
if you haven't heard that therapy is
good for you to do if you don't believe
it let me tell you it's good to do
therapy
and i got into it and it was so easy
because i went to
betterhelp.com and
i found myself a totally awesome
therapist because they have everything
that you want to focus on all of your
priorities they just cater the perfect
therapist to you and man i just had my
second session with my therapist karen
and um she's super cool dude and when i
get done talking to her i felt
way better about a bunch of different
things
so yeah man go to betterhelp.com but put
slash stevo
betterhelp.com
steve only get 10 off your first month
plus it's so unbelievably affordable
compared to if you go into somebody's
office and you don't even have to go
into anybody's office do it on a video
conference
so easy so helpful and you can get 10
percent off your first month by going to
betterhelp.com
stevo it's helping me and it's going to
help you too now let's talk about comics
being jerks
um they weren't supportive were they
some
weren't supportive right um
and uh
oh over here i mean it's a blessing and
a curse because you come in to stand up
with a built-in audience people know who
you are and so you're able to sell
tickets
whether you're good or not you know it's
so interesting that you said that
because r.i.p late charlie murphy
similar situation where he got his fame
from the show right right but the show
wasn't
giving him the fortune
right right so i created a i'm rich
[ __ ] tour and i
had to force charlie to go to open mic
for the first time and people were
really really critical of him first off
you're the older brother of one of the
best guys to ever do it yeah you know
what i'm saying so that's the challenge
because people can't wait to try to
compare you
but
like and even in your case the craziest
thing is like you're selling out
across the country pretty much as an
open micro
right and every
thing that you learned about it
you learn
at a higher level there's someone doing
a dive bar someone doing an open ride
it's like you come in with the fan face
so i know they had to be tough yeah i
mean it was jumping i wasn't selling out
you know like when i first started
touring as a stand-up um you know
jackass 3d was in [ __ ] theaters you
know because if we needed any way other
way to get jackass in your face
[Laughter]
not it's not enough yeah
we want you to be like duck and dick in
the theater
right
but even with the movie like being a big
success and still in theaters
um i wasn't selling out comedy clothes
people people had doubts about whether
they're gonna go to a comedy club to see
stevo and for the for the first number
of years
i i let it be like a mix of like circus
tricks and silly stunts and stand up and
and i based it all on like crazy stories
and [ __ ] i don't know i had my own
approach to it and it worked but but
yeah like i jumped the line i jumped on
and and and and [ __ ] had every
right to to present me for that but i
think what what but you know what i
don't [ __ ] agree with that bro
i like i say in the case charlie murphy
jeremy piven is another one perfect
example you don't you never know what a
person's passion was right you never
know if there's something i want to do
all of a sudden so what that you found a
different lane that gave you more fame
more fortune than starting from scratch
so i never
understood why comedians feel like
there's a certain trajectory or there's
a certain timeline to do it if a
[ __ ] catch it he catch it and be
good he's [ __ ] good you know i i got
this thing like uh
one guy who identified himself as not
being supportive of me getting into
stand-up was mark maron you know he
wasn't yeah and he was candid about that
but you know like bless his heart and i
respect his honesty he said hey you know
i consider myself a purist and the idea
of you coming in to stand up is like
kind of rubs me the wrong way you know
but what i mean i think people care
about [ __ ] they don't need to care about
right right but marc maron i love the
guy he loves people the wrong way too so
a philosophy about life that there are
essentially two types of people in the
world there are the mark marins and
there are the joe rogans and and i would
classify the mark merrigan the marc
maron mentality as one of scarcity
where he's actually like if if stevo
comes in and stand up and and is
successful then there's less for him you
know like i pose a threat but but that's
another and i thought that was just
in the black comedy circuit whatever but
everybody
acts like it's only one job
right it's more than one job i
understand it's so lame forever it's the
reason why you go to comedy club you got
lesbian night you got uh a black knight
you got it it's enough room for
everybody i never understood why people
think that this is the only job that you
got enough to go around right i mean and
then there's joe rogan he's got this
attitude of abundance man he says man i
wish my [ __ ] mailman would get into
stand-up because the guy's funny like if
you're funny then [ __ ] dude i feel
the same way about and i've i've um i've
been doing it for a long time
and i mentor people and out and people
think i'm crazy because i'll um
like if you if anybody
if i'm around people i was like some
people you know got it or may have it
and i'm like you should try it once no
i'm not no comedian and i tell them i
was like not to try it
to make it your job but just to try it
just to try it right because you never
know what's going to happen for you and
then you don't want to go your whole
life
watching all these people go ahead of
you you like yo i should have took a
shot at it right yeah it's interesting
because paul here is he's my producer my
editor
and uh you know i bring him on tour with
all the av [ __ ] because my show is
multimedia
and one day i just said hey
paul do i threw him on stage and said
[ __ ] put together five minutes and
get on stage did he do it yeah now he
opens every show
every time he's like five i'm up there
for like 12 minutes every time
but do you look him in his face and say
[ __ ] you're like that's appreciated
they don't even have a lights luckily
but man i love stories like that i come
i've had people come up to me
that like i'll look at a person in their
eyes right and if you got some people
you want to encourage to do it and their
eyes are talking [ __ ] you know the eyes
are saying maybe
oh one day or i need to write do you got
the people that's passionate about it
and if i can look in your face and i
could tell that you really
want to go on i'm gonna put you on i was
just in houston
texas
doing the improv
and you know uh willie willie willie d
from
ghetto boys
yeah uh british rebels and scarface so
willie d came to my show
and he told me he said yo d um
a good friend of mine known him since i
was 10 15 years old
um he just buried his
mother today
a lot of his family's in town i told him
to come out because i wanted them to um
just to try to break it up a little bit
just so i could
give them a good feel good and he was
like and my buddy he used to do comedy
like 20 years ago or whatever right i
was like cool so he wanted me to
give the family just like hey to uh
rodney god whatever the film i can't
remember
but he said he wanted me to give them a
shout out then the green room i told him
i said how about
i bring your boy on stage
right
and i thought i did that as i was
sincere but at the same time i was like
watch the answers gonna come back like
no i'm not really here for that
and i was like what do you do he said
he'll [ __ ] do it
and i'm um
uh and i told the emcee i said don't
[ __ ] give him an honest intro
tell him that you know
i'm a person that i'll give somebody
opportunity
not to the tragedy how tragic the day
was but just
honest like this guy don't want him to
come up here yeah says well sure and the
dude went up there
and um
he was he reminded me of you
he ran a [ __ ] light
i'm like yo [ __ ]
he didn't run the light but
he went up there he made a connection
with the audience
his family
had a moment where they could forget
not forget but at least have a good time
we we even went out because my thing
after shows i like to get private
karaoke rooms
and just do karaoke and i invited the
family out and i told my friends that it
was like just a blessing to be able to
it was very tragic weekend for them but
to be able to find some happiness some
way or whatever and i think those are
times that
i really really appreciate what i do as
a stand-up when it's when it affects
somebody like that that's dope
so were you saying charlie murphy was
reluctant to do stand-up but you had to
kind of push him to do it no i didn't
push him i bullied the [ __ ] oh
yeah
everything you think about charlie
murphy as far as far has been a tough
guy or anything yeah it's all true but
i used to always talk [ __ ] he always
talks [ __ ] you always talk [ __ ]
and he's always this bad [ __ ]
right
and i found something to get under his
skin right i said yeah you're a bad
[ __ ] until i put a goddamn
microphone in front of your face and
then you turn it to a [ __ ]
he wasn't having that [ __ ] yeah so again
we had an idea like we were doing a show
we weren't making a lot of money people
understand cable tv they think just
because you're on tv every month every
night you make a lot of money yeah but
usually it takes some years before you
get there sure the fair contract so we
had a level of popularity but our
pockets wasn't right you weren't rich
[ __ ] no it wasn't red [ __ ] not at all
and that was a horrible impression of me
i just wanted you to know i don't want
you to think like did i nail it
i was not trying to do like your vocal
cadence yo you made us like yo i could
have been the rich [ __ ] guy
yeah
again charlie never did stand up i used
to bully him all the time
i wanted to tour to be dope
so
uh bill burr i've told this story a lot
of podcasts bill burr bill burr was
probably
um
doing at that time b rooms and it's not
to be an insult insulting but it's just
where his career was but anybody who saw
bill burr his reputation everybody knew
he was about to blow up it was just a
matter of time
but i didn't want the show just to be
honest i needed 10 or 15 minutes out of
charlie he could have went up there and
just wave he had so much love that
people were quoting everything he said
charlie
what did that so we could [ __ ] trick
him with five minutes of that
but i was like i still want the show to
be strong i was headlining so i said
let's add bill bird to it so
you got the spectacle
of charlie murphy
you got the experience
and the [ __ ]
uh beast on stage
from bill byrne
and myself
and we have a solid show so the first
time i took him on stage he didn't
really do that well but it's hard to
gage because again
like yourself people loved him
yeah you know people loved him but then
after a while like after a while he he
his timing got better
he became a better storyteller
and the thing that i respect about
charlie is that he never let anybody
tell him who he should be
or i should perform because people
wanted him like well if you
pick up your pace like your brother
would he was like
i'm not my brother i'm me he found his
lane and he committed to it and to this
day people regard him
as one of the best storytellers to ever
ever do it and i like
being around charlie been around eddie
like i've been in their their uh
private family space
and you could tell just by being around
them
that when they were growing up that
charlie
was the funniest one in the family
you can tell now i'm not saying as a
performer but right just naturally tell
a story you know when you're around
people and your family everybody knows
this story but you only want to hear
from one person sure and he was a guy
like this you could be like eddie tell
us i'm sure everybody's like charlie
tell a story uh-huh you know charlie
would just hold court i mean i i
remember when i started doing it like he
was everywhere i mean when we're on this
circuit like we're all chasing each
other around we're
we're running a train on these clubs
first off how do you [ __ ] get a dog
you sleep you feeling back private no no
no um we were shooting at this tv show
down in peru and the production did all
the
the the the jumping through hoops oh
they did it and paul was there he was
the
in charge of the this whole digital you
know production side of it yeah that's
how we met
and and why i knew he was going to do
great
doing stand-up
yeah wow get ready for this to really be
pretty shocking and impressive you know
what else is shocking and impressive the
way that i've been killing it in the
merch game dude and you know what the
holiday rush is over but dude it's not
time to start slacking dude i'm
definitely not and you know how we do
our merch with ship station
it's like
one interface which brings together
all of your different uh carriers like
the post office ups fedex put it all
into one spot and even if you're selling
on amazon on your own website etsy you
name it whatever you're selling with and
however you're shipping it all in one
easy interface with the lowest rates
that you could get man they're normally
reserved for like fortune 500 fortune
500 companies but you can have a man and
on top of that you can have your
e-commerce going and humming and making
it so easy with the ship station and for
60 days not even pay for ship station
because i'm gonna give you a free trial
so you go to shipstation.com
you use the promo code stevo and to do
that when you get to shipstation.com you
click the microphone in the top right
corner and dude you get 60 days free
trial and no matter how big or small
your business is
this will do it my business got pretty
big we still use shipstation
loving it man so become a baller get
your ecommerce game going don't be a
slacker and use ship station to ship all
your orders man take it from me dude
it's the way to succeed now let's talk
about paul succeeding at stand up
is because on the last night of that
trip and
talented
well
on the last night we threw like a party
like a wrap party and i wandered up to
the roof of the four-story building we
were at and fell off of it you landed on
[ __ ] concrete rubble and
it was all fenced in so nobody the only
way you could see his ass is if you were
on the roof and nobody thinks to go on
the roof so it's the [ __ ] next day
and then all day they're looking for
paul they don't find no he's still on
the side no shut the [ __ ] up i was
laying there all day till like 4 p.m
they found me both of his lungs
punctured yeah only one of his lungs
collapsed but that's when you two got
close well i can't you need a story like
that dude
what [ __ ] healthy lung have an ass
[ __ ]
the last time you almost killed yourself
[ __ ] get out of here no i remember i
told you after i healed and came back i
told you like i was embarrassed about it
you know and you're like
what you're like that's dope you know
like because to you something like that
happening has always been good for you
you know did you at any point did you
say did anybody get that
yeah
you can't we look for footage there's no
no street camera nothing caught it damn
unfortunately but yeah sorry his his
first five minute set was fire
yeah i mean it's kind of easy that way
that i'm just telling this gnarly story
about almost dying and it's kind of
related to steve so it kind of
it does make a little easy for me but
man stand up is like
because i'm not necessarily pursuing
being a stand-up comedian but i would
recommend it to everybody because it's
scary as [ __ ] but like you go out there
you do it and like even if you do bad
you're not hurt like you're fine you
know like i would have i would believe i
would say
that
it could probably do
in regard to
mental health and therapy i think this
is probably something
where
you can have a class
to help people
with mental issues just by maybe
something where you can combat your
fears be in front of people or tell your
truth i think it's like because once you
once you do it
it's it could you can either get closer
to it or further away from it it could
be so scary to say [ __ ] that but so
challenge that you want to do it again
yeah i i i wish everybody sometime in
life try just just five minutes yeah i
agree yeah and yeah yeah
you know what it was stopped to
it would stop a lot of people from being
hecklers yeah sure
are you a heckler okay because that's
how most comedy clubs
get hecklers to shut up and that was the
case with me i started as a heckler
that's how you started that's amazing i
started as a heckler and i was the
cockiest heckler
out of washington d.c
i used to go there with people that i
used to work when i had a regular job
and i used to go to [ __ ] with the
hecklers i mean [ __ ] uh the comedians
and i would go every week and people
started coming
they was like yo is that [ __ ] guy
gonna be here today
like they wanted to know if i was part
of that show they wanted to see and i
got so cocky with being an [ __ ]
heckler i think after like five weeks i
went to the club owner and i tried to
get a door deal
as a heckler
[Laughter]
i said listen i've increased this
business by 30
i've done the numbers
i need to get my money they looked at me
like if you don't get the [ __ ] out of my
face that's amazing and they dared me to
go on stage and 27 years later like i
never looked back yeah
damn damn yeah dude i [ __ ] hate
hecklers dude i got into therapy over
that [ __ ] where the [ __ ] did your dog
just go it feel like
she
had a date or something like yeah like
just rolled out it came back like well
i've done my dirty street what do you
want to talk about right i just released
her into the neighborhood man even
though this isn't my our neighborhood
she's just kidding she does her own
thing man she could see if he's here
she's just gonna [ __ ] off and go check
out your neighborhood look she's like
these [ __ ] talking about me
again yeah yeah she's like watch this um
so
before the
chappelle show
that's that
when did the chappelle show come out
that was i think 2000 around 2003 2004
if i'm not mistaken right and and that
so you were
deep in stand up
i think i was probably
at that time probably like
four years into it okay yeah but my four
years was like
dog ears just felt like it was
multiplied by like i came out
like someone said to you like the first
experience i ever had on stage it was a
good one i go to standing ovation
and i was going through the ranks really
really fast in washington dc
i think i was only doing like six or
seven months before i decided that
there was nothing else that i could do
in dc not to be insulted into that
comedy scene but
i just felt like if i stayed it too much
longer i was gonna be one of those like
hometime heroes
you know goddess like everybody know he
does all the bowling alley gigs and
stuff i just wanted to
start at the bottom of the um
of the next level and i was getting
a certain level of success the crazy
thing was when i first started when i
moved to new york i was lucky enough to
get an agent probably like a year into
it
and i started booking a lot of dramatic
stuff
like the first thing i booked was a law
episode of law and order which every
actor in new york they say you're not an
actor in new york
if you hadn't been on law and order you
know like three different shows
everybody that was pretty much
everybody's introduction to acting
um
i was doing a lot of dramatic stuff it
wasn't until chappelle show people
thought
that i was a dramatic actor
they was like yo now he's trying to be
funny i was like no i've always been
funny and that was the first platform
that showcased me as a uh
on on the comedy side of it right
and that
so
you're
you got like like you described you had
to pay your dues you're not getting paid
a whole lot of money from comedy central
but it's getting renewed and and then
all of a sudden the numbers are getting
crazy like
famously chappelle walks away from 50
million bucks
like by that point it's not trump change
anymore no that was his money he walked
away from it not me [ __ ]
you're looking to be like we both walked
away
[Laughter]
like dave you're ready to hold hands out
like i'm dave i'm about to cheat on you
yeah it's not gonna work i don't think i
could have done it
right i thought i could have done it but
we was um
it was just bubbling and the best thing
for me was that
people that saw me doing different
projects like def jam bet it was
scattered premium blend but this was the
first platform where
like
i was i mean like it was just pop
culture you know what i'm saying it's
one thing to be on
a lot of shows mixed up it's one thing
to be on one show that
everybody's tuning to right it was
before dvr
this is before like oh i'm gonna stream
it later it was like
[ __ ] i gotta watch it at ten
o'clock on wednesday
because i wanna be able to quote
everything from the show the next day
yeah so although i think that
of course i believe that my career would
it would have did his thing but that did
really like get people like oh [ __ ]
like who is this guy and i had a ball
doing it yeah dude i bet it looked fun
yeah and and uh
i i mean i feel like i i relate to it a
little bit because with jackass jackass
was it was real big
and uh
when it was a tv show but little kids
were showing up in hospitals [ __ ]
trying to do their own jackass [ __ ] i
know and that's
did you ever feel i know it's kind of
tough because
did you ever feel like
you guys were responsible for that or
when you were thinking like you should
i'm not here to be your parent i'm not
here to tell you dude
did you ever
i mean
my feeling was that i'm an attention
horde i'm not trying to share the
spotlight so i'm not
encouraging anybody to do that you know
i think darwin would have been pretty
okay with it
like whatever [ __ ] them kids
right yeah i mean if you're like you
know and and my other little you know
cocky thing i would say is that it's not
tony hawk's fault every time a kid falls
off a skateboard you know like i'm a
[ __ ] professional dude doing this
[ __ ] um but but the point was that when
when those kids were
getting hospitalized copying our stunts
um mtv got real scared of the liability
of it all and they started cracking down
on us and giving us all these rules and
we're not allowed to do that wow so when
did the disclaimer come in because i
know it was the beginning was from the
beginning oh yeah but but it was when
they started telling us what we could
and couldn't do and we filmed stuff but
they wouldn't show it
[ __ ] comedy central
would tell
[ __ ] what they can't do right
you know
i know i'm all over the place but it's
funny that you say that
and i've had uh work with common sense
but
one of the biggest sketches we did on
chappelle show
was uh the rick james sketch sure
right i used to do the warm-ups and the
wrap-arounds
and
i and i
we would introduce these sketches
but this one particular sketch i've
never felt like the room just would
shatter
right
comedy central
hated the sketch
their notes where
the sketch is too long because the first
time that anybody our show was a half
hour
it's the first time that one sketch
pretty much took the whole show
they said it was too long and
they also said that they didn't think
charlie murphy was funny
cut too
much
you know it was just interesting like
it's just i guess i'm saying it's like a
lot of times people don't
know the inside and what you have to go
through
as an artist
to get your vision out there
the way you want to be seen and not just
the way the executives want to be seen
right for sure
and interestingly our jackass director
now lives in rick james's old house
in l.a or laurel canyon i know he'd be
finding bags of cocaine and [ __ ]
that's like a treasure hunting [ __ ] like
your kids are playing hide and seek
looking for the rick james bishop right
but there was nobody like
for me
and i'm a huge fan of dave as performer
friend and everything
for him
to be able to embody
the character of rick james and i know
for the most part when you connect with
a character is because
first thing like they look like the
person
he didn't look [ __ ] like rick james but
just [ __ ] nailed that [ __ ] man yeah
and i was going through some old youtube
videos the other day
and i saw all a video
of rick james and tina marie singing a
classic of fire and desire it was a duet
right and as a kid growing up was one of
my favorite songs and it only took me
four minutes to listen to it
i've never seen anybody do a song for
like 30 minutes
like it just kept on the performance the
interaction and then when i saw rick
jennings like that and then i saw with
dave i was like he really embodied that
character know that [ __ ] yeah same with
prince he doesn't look like prince at
all but like yeah he just embodies that
i remember david dave asked for a person
if he wanted to be in it
and he said you're crazy you know what
that's chris white you're crazy but do
it but he was a fan of um dave and he
was a fan of the show how crazy would
that have been if principal did a guest
spot
just the fact that knowing that prince
played basketball
in heels
yeah right but the crazy thing about
that charlie murphy had
thousands of stories like that
that's how that sketch was born it was
like
just table talk doing at lunch
charlie just telling stories and then i
was like yo man we should just basically
[ __ ] let charlie talk and then we
write the sketch sketch after yeah so
was there another story of his that
you're like we should do that one too
and you just never were able to do it uh
no the ones that we should have done
um i'm not privy to talk about it okay
okay
i could have never done it no no i'll
just take that to my grave yeah there
you go i did like if i'm drinking with
some people right in my mouth but i'll
just keep those to myself okay but i'll
just say me and charlie has some great
adventures i believe it's for sure
so so when you showed up in cancun on
that that credited this [ __ ] huge
like 30 foot video wall this like
stadium [ __ ] arena stage and then
this half-assed little sofas in front of
it all like uh
like you were on the phone with the
chapel huh like
yeah you were like walking around on the
stage i think you had a show like uh
like uh yeah before mine maybe in the
same scene i think yeah i did i came in
before you i was just telling how crazy
this
but
i like i really before i perform
i look at my situation right and i
noticed the same things that you noticed
it wasn't a space for comedy right too
far away too much so
i didn't even perform on stage
i went on the audience wow
i i went out of the audience i was like
there's no way i'm going to make a
connection with this audience
with me being on this big ass goddamn
runway stage
look like some [ __ ] supposed to be a
fashion week in italy or some [ __ ] like
that
and i said um i need to be closer to the
people so i got off stage and i was
within two to three feet
of the audience and um and i made my way
through the audience and i know that
they appreciate that performance more
than jimmy just been on stage it didn't
feel comfortable wow okay i had to
improvise i've been in situations like
that before
i was like you know you sometimes gotta
make some choices that
uh production might not agree with
because you got the guy
that's working a camera like i'm getting
paid to follow you on stage not in the
[ __ ] audience but right i'm a person
i always want to give to my audience
first and i made it work
yeah i did and you've probably done
you've done a lot of like stadiums in
arenas opening for chappelle and stuff
like that right yeah so electric man
i mean
i appreciate
every space that i work from doing an
open mic with 30 people
to performing for upwards of 24 25 000
people
but it feels like all the work that you
put in
in those dive bars
in those spots where the jokes didn't
work
where you were limited where something
happened you were tested
it feels like all of that is for those
stages
you know i used to get like
really nervous
going doing the arena stuff but then i
just
i don't know something about the last
time we did mgm grand
i felt like a [ __ ]
you a big
ufc guy
but it felt like i was going into the
octagon it was like
no way for me not to let that energy go
through me i remember one of the first
times i bit did one of those bigger
ruins it was with
dave and it was with uh joe
and you get your adrenaline pumping but
then there's another level
when joe rogan does your intro
yeah you don't feel like
y'all i'm like i'm not gonna go tell
joe's i'm about to go try to beat the
[ __ ] out of somebody
i'm like mr elk meat himself right you
already missed it mr elk meat [ __ ]
jalapenos blood dripping from his
elk heart himself
it's almost like
he's
putting the orders up there for you to
with flock of field flea or wedding [ __ ]
but it was like
[Laughter]
no goddamn days off i'm forced to rip
this audience but
man
when i
go on in those venues especially when i
work with dave and i do the intro and
they'll say uh
i'll comment coming up tonight they'll
say a couple of things you've seen them
on hbo's dwyer and i might get a couple
chuckles you've seen them in spider-man
2. it might be a couple of people to
remember that
but man it never fails man just a
tribute to like what we did to pop
culture
but when they say but
you fell in love with him
as as she learned
and
the place
goes
bananas
and it just feels like you're in one of
situations where you got to stand up you
know i'm saying like i'm like this i
can't let these people down it's one
thing to get you'll get chris rock said
it yeah being famous will get you your
first minute and a half yeah you know
it's like oh my god remember if it's
awesome but after that you got to bring
it
so it feels good knowing that
people appreciate you but at the same
time you still gotta you still gotta put
it right that was my first experience
the first time i ever tried stand up i
had this guy was 2006 this this guy uh
asked me to come do a stunt at the
comedy club at the laugh factory and i'm
like all right cool man i'll do that and
i showed up and i just thought man
there's no crazier stunt than if i try
to stand up
i'm trying to think of like a joke you
know
i'm like [ __ ] man what am i gonna do
and i
so i get on stage
and and they're they're like steve oh
you know the crowd is [ __ ] excited to
see me i'm like damn they're they're
rooting for me man they're they're
excited to see me but when they root for
you people root for you to [ __ ] yourself
up too right
it's like going to nascar they want to
see the race but can we kids get two
cars to crash right yeah yeah so i get
on stage and i go hey everybody i'm in
the mood for a [ __ ] does anybody want
one and like they laugh you know and
then i felt really good and i [ __ ]
got the [ __ ] off the stage right no i
think i remember you working at but not
at that time
but you
acknowledged giving somebody a [ __ ]
oh dude okay
okay no no
what it was was it was something on it i
mean it was a joke that i could never
get close to it was that what
what it was was it's your land you can
have it
it was um a
transgender individual
who looked a lot like a really
attractive woman
but uh
maybe had a penis right and definitely
sucked mine okay
i know a penis got sucked not to be
confused with the jerk off joints but i
knew somebody got these dicks
special i hope i didn't trip over any
rules on that one
look look how rumors start right you had
your version
did i have my version in 10 years from
now to go like esd remember that time
you took it took it in the [ __ ]
it was like no he gave me a [ __ ] i
gave her a blog
there was this one time i did kiss my
buddy on the dick my buddy party that's
why but you know that's
i mean i
that's white boyfriend
yeah like y'all could do that [ __ ] and
be friends
when i say black people do that it's
gonna be a murder the next day right you
know what's like this like i don't give
i don't trust you saying you can keep a
secret
no witnesses
yeah i know how we can just deal with
this [ __ ] yeah
man that's funny damn man so so uh
dude ted tell me about your podcast man
we're getting ready to well
podcast is a donna rollins show
i started it probably two years ago okay
and then i was i had always
kind of thought about being in the
podcast world
but then i was like oh that means you
got to get guests oh dude's the word yo
i'm like i don't want to call nobody you
know i mean like i was like and i was
going through if i would do it i was
like well if i do a podcast i was like
the only guess i'm going to have on the
podcast is me
right okay
like like bill bird's mind yeah bill
burke
i was like maybe i'll do it like that
but then i
kind of was like everybody's doing the
podcast i want to be different
and i remember the first time i did um
rogan's show
and i was talking to him about you know
me being i think first time i did was
like three years ago and i got a young
son i think my son was like two or three
at the time and i was telling him as
much as i do loved being on the road
it's like i wanted to spend more time
with my son yeah but i'm i'm a comedian
that
you know i don't really
i don't have to get tv money i don't
have to get movie money i just need to
get money so if i can find my money in
the road i'm not tripping off of
being a serious regular long as i could
make a fair limit that way so i was
happy to be on the road but then it was
taken away from my time my son and i was
telling joe i said i want to um
i said i need to come off the road i say
but i don't make any money in hollywood
i said i gotta reintroduce myself to
hollywood i need to be able to make
money in hollywood
and he was like oh just
start a podcast right and i'm saying to
myself
no this was me being stupid
i was like you ain't no money in podcast
and i've forgot that i'm
talking about that
mr daddy wartbox a podcast right and i
didn't i was like you know money pocket
and i said
cause i had youtube followers some years
ago and i had this brand manager or
whatever that we had a little issue
and he took down all my pages i had like
35 000 subscribers on youtube i'm like
man i got to start by getting one person
at a time i gotta
ask people to come on the show
everything and the birth of my podcast
was on joe rocket show he's like it's
simple danielle he just makes everything
seem so calm he's like
i was like how am i going to get it out
there he was like you do the podcast
i'll tweet about it
like i'll put on my social media
then you'll do the rounds but the other
people next to you know it'll be popping
and and he was to a certain extent
he was right but then right when i was
starting to get my groove
the uh pandemic pandemic hit and it
changed everything that was the only
thing that placed one of the best
platforms for me to showcase whatever
you consider my comedic skill set is
and i just kept doing it
kept doing it it was going along and
then once things started opening back up
i started hitting the road i
didn't commit to it as i did at the
beginning because i'm like [ __ ] and
then i gotta go get
the money i'm supposed to get sure but
then i fell in love with it because
it's a perfect platform to
be
your own director
your own producer
your own ep
nobody can [ __ ] tell you what to do
and it's i think for comics it's the
place for you to have your most honest
voice and i'm i'm far i fell in love
with it first time i ever tried to do it
i was i was like i was like i don't need
nobody first time i tried
so i got this dude i'm like yeah we're
gonna do my podcast it's about to be on
right
and i
it's tough to just talk to yourself
you know people like bill bird
those guys that can do it like that's a
different level for sure right and i was
doing my podcast
i got 10 minutes into my first podcast
and i quit
i was like this i said man [ __ ] this i
ain't doing this punk ass podcast [ __ ]
right
so my producer slash friend he was like
what are you doing
i was like i quit
he said you can't just quit your podcast
i said okay whose podcast is it
he said it's you and i say well i quit
my [ __ ] and you're fired for telling me
when i can't [ __ ] quit
and i did that once then i did another
made another attempt of it in my car
and then kate quigley
good friend of mine
she was in big into the podcast joint
and she's like you gotta do it you gotta
do it just do it you gotta do it so she
found me a producer the first couple of
episodes we ever did well and i'm
forever grateful to her ever grateful to
joe rogan ever forever grateful
to david deary julius everybody help me
but she pushed me into it
and when i first started i could have
went and tried to make it a big
production get the best studio the best
lighting but i was like if i do that
i i won't give people opportunity to
grow with me i said let's do it as
bootleg
as possible
so people can expect mistakes
you know i'm saying like people's like
and it was critical of me at the
beginning but i was like this is how i
learn you know because the podcast
people
are
a lot of them
are [ __ ]
you know you talk about wannabe
community so critical to everything it
was like like you can't make these
[ __ ] happy
yeah it's like yeah dude uh i like it
but maybe you need to get different
microphones like
yeah they'll be like yeah you need a
booster for that or like i would bump it
up to it so-and-so
and yell the camera but i was like you
know what it's okay because i said i
always want to grow and i'm saying we
have issue with the lighting we correct
that if we have issues with the cell we
correct that so he went from doing it in
kate quigley's apartment
to finding a home at the um
the hollywood improv i want to shout
them out because it was really good
to us during the podcast when nobody
would let you in the building whatever
they were sneakers in
and we just had a nice little safe place
to upstairs that's we did it everywhere
we did it um okay we started in um
and um bud's office that was the first
place we did it then we went down to i
think the lab
did we were one did show in the main
room they went to the bar we're like we
hit everything in there but big shout
out to ricardo and
everybody uh
rita paige everybody yeah they were so
cool with us
and now we just um
moved into a
studio situation which works better for
me because then i could just just like
this is the best situation you could
just be driving down the street it's
like [ __ ] it you want to do one so it's
been a good experience and it's one of
course is on youtube and all podcast
platforms and
i'm having fun with it you know i've got
my uh
podcast guy who sells our ads and [ __ ]
um you know i i kind of looked to him
for for guidance for advice and it's
like when people ask me to do a podcast
like i'll ask him hey you should think i
should do this podcast and every single
time i ask that question the answer is
look on apple podcast and see how many
ratings it has and if it has less than 1
000 ratings then the answer is no
because that means they have no [ __ ]
audience you're wasting your time
talking to nobody if they have over a
thousand ratings then the answer is yes
because that's a meaningful audience and
i looked up here to one point five
thousand that's it i don't even know
what happens that's it how do you know
i i didn't even know that and i was
wondering because there was like i was
like will he do my podcast i guess your
guy was checking the ratings before he
said yes
i was like i need to answer now right
like what the [ __ ] are you doing
one second steve's looking at your
[ __ ] ratings
but i look at it i look at it
i always say
i tell my guys my pocket is not i said
it's a reality show by the podcast
the mechanics of it like the
personalities and working with different
people like i think that's more
interesting and i know that was the
biggest thing for me like
my [ __ ] don't add up
with what with when i say with my
popularity and people it doesn't but i
also realize that if you want something
on something you got to put the time
into it yeah it's not going to be easy
it's not going to be overnight and i
look at it like this
as i grow
as it grows it'll maybe it'll come to a
point where when people really catch on
to it now they'll start digging into the
archive
and see what the [ __ ] they
did what they missed yeah you're talking
like you don't have it i think the the
sense i get is that you got as
successful as podcast that's coming but
then but i'm looking at like and i'm not
to compare but i'm looking at the guys
that do the major numbers of course i
want to get there but i always got to
realize it takes time and i even told
rogan on his podcast anytime somebody
comes into the podcast world the first
person to say they want to be joe rogan
right but you want to be joe rogan now
right right you don't want to be joe
rogan when nobody believed in it you
don't want to be joe rogan he was like
hey there's this new thing that's coming
out i'm telling you you didn't want to
be the blood and sweat joe rogan you
want to be the spotify joe rogan you
want to be right the [ __ ] that
got
like [ __ ] gas chambers or whatever
that [ __ ] white boy [ __ ] he got in
this podcast
submerging tanks and dishonest yeah
everybody wants to be that rogan
sure you don't want to be the rogan when
he had to deal with starting the hair
loss rogan right nobody wants to deal
with that i don't think he made a penny
on his podcast for years yeah i remember
like the the old school rogan when when
bill burr was in the room when i was
just a big [ __ ] marijuana club there
was like [ __ ] eight people in the
room or you know the comedy cellar and
[ __ ] [ __ ] well one thing i got the
ice house i mean one thing i respect
and joe was very instrumental in me
getting out the gate he's still been a
good friend of me i still call him for
advice about things
one thing i respect about him is his
dedication to being the best stand-up he
can be yeah because a lot of people they
do this people do it for different
reasons people do it for therapy some
people do it for the cash
you know some people like this i just
want to pay that that's why you see some
[ __ ] don't really work on any
actors like this they're just collecting
this they just it's a money grab
they do the same [ __ ] 10 15 years saying
[ __ ]
but
that [ __ ]
is true
to comedy
being a multi multi
multi multi-millionaire
to still commit to doing shows when he
was here every night yeah every night
you don't have to do that it's you know
he could really
he could deal with one heckler
and he could say i'm rich
and stick to [ __ ]
and mean it but i respect and i respect
any anybody get to a certain amount of a
level of suspect uh a certain level
of respect and a fortune to still be
passionate about it and the dude is
still that way that's why i can say they
don't want the dopes to do it yeah
ma'am well hey dude what do you say we
go do your podcast i don't want to i
don't want you to do my [ __ ] let me
go go check your rating
yeah ready
you want to
you want to sneak raining on me let me
go check my rate
right i'm gonna come back like yeah
that's it for me tonight guys yeah
that's the light guys that's my light
thank you
thanks for having me i appreciate it man
i couldn't wait to tell people how
disrespectful you were to me man
good stuff man you're a legend man
appreciate everything you did for comedy
everything you did for the culture and
everything all kidding aside
were you offended by me in cancun no no
i couldn't wait to talk i like i
couldn't wait to run into you somewhere
just to talk [ __ ] okay it just so
happened that i could do it on your
pocket so this is a better platform even
better man he's an [ __ ] he runs
cool i just give me um just a couple
minutes yeah
but thank you man hey thank you
about that you know he was really
breaking my balls
um
but whatever dude i went and did his
podcast after that we had a blast man
love darnell rawlings
and um dude
did i mention at the top of this episode
that i'm on my own tour bus
you can see
wow i mean some of you can see
it's [ __ ] pretty crucial dude
i mean come on
look at the other side it's kind of
cooler
yeah dude
otherwise it's not all the way out
oh well
[ __ ] daddy i'm going back to bed